ces images ont déjà fait le tour du
monde pendant le journal télévisé le
plus populaire de russie une femme
surgit derrière la présentatrice
pancartes à la main il y est écrit
arrêtez la guerre ne croyait pas la
propagande ici on vous ment le direct
est tout de suite interrompu cette femme
s'appelle marianne a aussi yannick obein
journaliste de la chaîne après son
intervention elle a immédiatement été
arrêté
sa page facebook a depuis été inondé de
messages de soutien son courage a même
été salué par le président ukrainien
je suis reconnaissant aux russes qui ne
cesse d'essayer de transmettre la vérité
et combattre la désinformation
je pense particulièrement à la femme qui
est entré dans le studio de channel one
avec une affiche contre la guerre rogers
a aimé la censure est de plus en plus
dur en russie où montré une feuille
blanche vous vaut d'être arrêté par la
police
sur la place rouge cette femme montre
aussi une pancarte à la caméra où il est
littéralement écrit deux mots est-ce que
je vais être arrêté pour ça en son genre
d une manière de montrer que quoi qu'on
dise il est interdit de s'exprimer en
russie ce député du parti communiste en
a aussi fait les frais lors de ce débat
télévisé pour avoir évoqué l'amitié
entre les peuples il se fait sortir du
plateau d'auge voyez un sweat-shirt et
novopress les méchas et senna bra bottes
boots aidé à préparer à kingston
en russie une nouvelle loi était adoptée
début mars tout discours jugé subversif
à propos de l'armée est passible de 15
ans de prison les journalistes
indépendants et étrangers ont pour la
plupart fui le pays et les autres sont
réduits au silence